Today is my husband and I's fourth wedding anniversary,
so I decided to wake up super early
and make some bagels and cream cheese from scratch.
I started by making my bagel dough
by combining warm water with yeast,
adding some flour,
brown sugar, and salt.
I needed that in my mixer until it came together,
and then I turned it out
and needed it by hand for another six to eight minutes.
Once that was soft to the touch,
I put it in my oil bowl
and covered it with a shower cap and a kitchen towel.
Then I got started on making my cream cheese.
So I added some whole milk to my pot
with some lemon juice
and let that go until it curdled.
Once all the way was separated,
I poured it into my strainer
lined with a cheese cloth
and let that cool
and then pressed out all the liquid,
added that to my food processor,
and let that go until it was smooth.
In the meantime,
I pulled my garlic out of the oven,
let that cool
while I sliced up some chives
and added both of those things to my cream cheese
with a good pinch of salt and some of that olive oil.
By this point,
my dough was almost double in size,
so I cut it into eight pieces
and form those into little balls
before poking a little hole in them
and stretching that out to resemble a bagel.
I Repeated that process with all eight pieces,
and then covered those
while I prep my honey and water,
add all of my toppings laying out.
And then the bagels went in the water
for about a minute on each side
before I put them on my Parchment paper. Paper.
I brushed some egg wash on them
and then layered my toppings on.
So I did a few different ones.
Sesame, smoked
sea salt, cheddar,
and Fresno chili.
I baked those for about 25 minutes,
and they came out looking so perfect.
But he always needs his toasted,
so he did that,
and he gave them a 10 out of 10,
which is very rare.
I was very pleased with that.
And then I made mine with my roasted garlic and chive
cream cheese
and the pickles I made the other day.
At this point, look,
he's already had three bagels,
so I would say he enjoyed it.